welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so this week it was announced that the
ball queen will most definitely be
returning to picard series two now there
is kind of an obvious reason why that
might be towards the end of series one
in picard we do see
seven of eye taking over a ball cube
there has been lots of rumors that is
she going to be the new queen
maybe what 709 did is going to force the
queen's hand
and she's going to have to come back to
retake her throne
well
those rumors seem not to be true as we
have a ball queen in the cast for series
two
but what does that mean and what do we
already know about the card series two
well
we know there is a new showrunner and we
know that that sugar in it is a huge
star trek fan so i'm really hoping to
see this channel go in a slightly
different direction away from just the
journey of picard and the quite slow
nature of it
i want to see far more star trek i want
to see some more of star fleet
we know data is going to be returning or
at very least we know the actor brent
spiner is going to be returning i'm kind
of hoping that's going to be in a
different guys
and maybe also not just in piccadas and
memory
we know obviously the cue is going to be
in this episode and
we have hints that there's going to be a
lot of time travel involved in the
series we have the hourglass with the
sand traveling backwards
we have picard stood in the front of
starfleet offices wearing his admiral's
uniform
we have seven of nine
who appears
not to have been assimilated
are these alternative timelines or is
this cue
playing tricks
the trial
never ends what else do we know
well if the borg is going to make a big
part of this series we're going to
hopefully see a lot more of what makes
the queen the queen we never actually
saw a ball queen until the movies but
then through voyager we saw a little bit
more
the explanation of what the queen is is
still vague
how does it work within the board
collective i am the borg
that is contradiction
the borg have a collective consciousness
there are no individuals
i am the beginning
the end
the one who is many
is this one being or is this several
beings are we going to see different
iterations of the ball queen um actually
the new show runner has
worked on comics and things in the past
and we have seen
images of the ball queen that they're
way more out there than what we've seen
on the tv so far but that's always beta
cannon and we always kind of take that
with a pinch of salt i do personally
have a little bit of a theory on this
i'm reminded of a voyager episode
q junior diverts a ball cube and borg
appear on the voyager bridge one is
about to assimilate janeway when the
queue appears
and makes them disappear
[Music]
we were just getting to the good part
if the continuums told you once they've
told you a thousand times
don't provoke the borg but why is that
if the queue really is all-powerful like
they say they are then why would they be
worried about antagonizing the borg
well the bulk have already shown that
they're not just content with completely
taking over the galaxy which is actually
a distinct possibility for them
given enough time
they actually want to look into
different dimensions of space they've
already invaded fluidic space
do the queue know
that actually their continuum is at risk
from a borg invasion we also know the
borg are more than happy to use time
travel see we saw that during first
contact when they attempted to use time
travel to assimilate the earth
it does seem that if the continuum has a
threat within the galaxy
it might just be the borg
and are we going to see that threat
potentially play out in series 2 of
picard i've got to say that two of my
favorite things from tng were the q and
the borg
and i am really excited about picard
series 2. even though i got to say
picard series 1
did let us down a little bit
particularly with the final scene i know
i've said this in other videos but that
final scene in picard series one where
the fleet appear
it's not just that it was badly done and
that the ships were ugly and boring
just a huge letdown
and i'm hoping
for card series two they've learned
their lessons
so
with the news that we're definitely
getting the queue the brent spiner is
returning again and that we have a new
borg queen
can we expect series 2 of picard to be
everything we hope
please leave a comment to tell me what
you're hoping to see in series two tell
me where you think the queue and the
borg are going to fit in
and please like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us
[Music]
you